and just like that we have we have
liftoff so on the line everybody
hilarious consolation match we're gonna
get a lot of listening into them Robert
and I are probably going to mostly be oh
my god
supposed to be fast eh uh let's let's
what as soon as we're ready I can't wait
to hear what Ludwig is saying that guy
is first of all just crazy oh man let's
go let's listen
oh oh well he's kind of ruining my plan
here by going for a mate
okay well I had a whole plan here uh
can't I sworn it by just bringing my
bishop to f3
Bishop to f3 blocks he's not even doing
it right
does he think he's doing it right left
three no he's right he's right he's not
even doing it right cuz he's not doing
it right
I assume he knows he's not doing it
right right
he's supposed to go here you can't
all right well my whole plan was
thwarted oh my gosh when he was loading
up that I had no idea what was about to
come out of it I can't believe he had a
response for the kudos I never gave
slick or the credit but he truly is a
brilliant player he just called slicker
a brilliant player yeah
buddy looks like you should get some
laundry off he might be the smartest man
I know it's part of his scenery yeah we
had Leslie on earlier I mean her her
streaming room looks like a place I want
to go to it's like so like well we
didn't get away thank bishop it looks
like you could like go right from
families hanging out and our buddy
Swifter also like has a really good set
up his place but my favorite has to be I
mean just Slater just look at this guy
yeah he just we gotta listen in on
slicker yeah but I mean I might even win
if I win this game is because I held my
piss inside of me I didn't go to the
bathroom and every time I went to the
bathroom I think it made me lose
motivation signification right I know I
will not let you guys down I ain't gonna
let you guys down we throw we die I will
never make the Owen 6/1 miserable I will
never make you guys look like idiots we
are an army
we are nothing but I see what he done
he's gonna try and take this
[Music]
[Laughter]
you chide you sir wait I could have
moved this out instead he just took me
to in order to take that but then if I
believe this
my god OKC tomorrow I'd be oh my gosh I
can't draw this war with him on with him
on audio that was it's unbelievable that
was literally almost just spit out my my
iced coffee with nothing else in it
he's playing super well wanna hear love
with sure oh well you just cast what's
liquor just allowed Bishop takes c6 oh
damn its liquors good
you
we just have that both on at the same
time not possible let's have them both
on I know they're talking over each
other but I want to hear what they're
both saying let's just say you're Danny
we're not needed let's just play
you
I don't understand this guy mom I really
don't understand this guy
you
God check again to mr. this might
actually wait hold on hold on a free
bishop genic hi this one could be beige
you
damn he's good he is good
you think that what Ludwig said is true
that if you eat a banana on an empty
stomach it's bad for your heart
I wouldn't take what he says too
seriously
I'm Maggie I'm not trying to lean
scientific insights from Ludwig
okay so white could have an attack here
if Ludwig finds this a-four a-five idea
the king is open everybody but a whites
down a piece I need to start activating
more pieces okay he realizes that needs
actually the pieces of it and if you're
slicker you're trying to save your king
and also Queen g5 would be a nice move
of black offering the Queen trade and
hoping that love would doesn't see it
yeah double attack actually G Paula Deen
queen easiest thing for somebody who's
not so experienced
he forges he's gonna move this down here
so in order to threaten this checkmate
in three if he sees in everybody I want
to chime what did I just do wrong why is
it checkmate this you can't go anywhere
stupid oh well my eyes oh we could take
this no he can't
is there something that could take this
know you could go here
oh my god are you serious
are you serious yo I just I went here if
I went here
dude though we played a couple good
moves in a row now yes he's protecting
this King wanna hear what he has to say
good yes do it wait it's still dead and
the music is one where you like I don't
even know is he if it's worth listening
to love with right now I mean he's just
he's so nervous you could tell he cares
he definitely does also because it's
looking these guys probably think that
the other ones a clown and so you know
you don't want to lose to you to these
guys but they're both actually improving
a lot and gonna do whatever sedation of
love wit but it's hard because I have a
mask for it
he's too it's too high damn the kadosh
you know what not that good I I've got
myself in a bit of a pickle here
sometimes slicker is even better on mute
[Laughter]
slickers absolutely hysterical yesterday
he was listening to to pot and playing
chess and it was just an amazing
combination am is POC the queen is the
weakest piece of the board is when the
queen is attacked it must move
what kind of using is love a plane right
now it's too soon
I can't hear it it's like I'm in an
elevator
oh you're not listening lovely I am I
think I am but the music is too is too
quiet on my Adly those Gerald Kasparov
you think Kasparov
let me turn him up
do you called the black queen Cheryl I I
don't ask the questions that I don't
think you said like Cheryl has a plan or
something I don't know what he said
after after he Queen takes e4 OS so
you're gonna find a checkmate this time
okay
the threat is Queen e2 made everybody
Bishop d2 is a good move though writing
cuts the Queen off from the C file yeah
and everything's defended but I don't
know that Ludwig is gonna find that move
slicker was going nuts by the way I find
slicker to be the funniest person ever
he said Gerald Kasparov is what the
chats on at the same time it feels worth
ending up in this position for a pin oh
my gosh imagine instead of coin Gary use
like hey Jerry 15 know your game against
Karpov what is my area outside of that
you know what okay you do something your
this is the problem with this is now
Queen e2 is in May but it wins the rook
the King has to go to c1 so I think
slick I think slickers not gonna mess it
up this time
yeah I think he's got a big he's
rewinding the bishop caps on e6
I think he's reminding himself the
things that he's lost yeah oh my gosh
can you imagine having like Garry
Kasparov and thank you correct move is
something like Magnus Costanza this
would be great
oh by the way like if okay Queenie
choose the only way to do it if Queen d3
I don't know it could they have to Queen
d3 check no bigger move okay Oh bug is
alive still that seems good too
the music is heating up a little bit too
so he's like feeling the energy yep
wait
but he's down a full queen right I mean
we lost he's completely dead and there's
a there's a lot of ways that flicker
could put this away but with every move
you don't put your opponent away II won
I was gonna be one of the Ryan but I
blacked out I go II won threatened the
Queen the Queen has to move where does
the Queen reveal the available space
while still being in a threatening
position would be d3 also slicker is
changing like I'm watching his stream -
he's like changing his stuff be popping
around seven time of his life am I
scared of we need Reno good I beat you
to it
maybe I should be just yet right should
be over in seconds yet but the stranger
things have happened
I'm guessing there's a window no rider
reference you want to make sure we throw
up I'm trapped in the wallpaper we're
flipping back to slicker let's do it oh
my god what did I just do what did I
just do no no no that's fine it's fine
if he takes the rook I can take him with
a notch a check I laugh in anticipation
of him saying something funny yeah I
don't chase if he attacks but now he's
actually focus check no I could just
retaliate but no no no no no he can't
you can't me if I just take this rock i
checkmated him
you can't me if I just take it I take it
yeah I put 250 gifted so mouths sure you
look basta me believe me cause it's a
check I just don't know he was that
stupid was that stupid cuz you could
take a pretty stupid move as a pretty
pretty stupid move it's a pretty stupid
move I'll be honest not the other
was a very stupid thief right there
maybe
Allah he said why why here this is like
okay I can't so regular Lego hey yes I
can't what my mouse slips if I'm if hey
I should be able to be safe so I could
go up and take if lower comes back and
with this ability piece a piece a piece
a piece a bait for what a good person
thank you safe good advice right now
stay home watch yes exactly I can't lose
this mind a con oh my god
if he takes my queen then I've lost oh
my god I need to full focus here I need
to full focus me what can I do
he's a red sock in check by the way the
time is the problem for a lovely I mean
that's not the only problem
he's getting out trash dog he's losing
on the board and he's losing on the
clock it's too quiet
oh my god was a check oh okay you gave
up another piece oh dude this is okay of
course is still totally without please
smile
Karim edible smile Karim edible smile oh
my god I can't take this
oh my god I need to I need to do
something anything just think don't just
think think what you doing bro think
what you're doing think we're doing we
doing bro we do mrs. repeat we do it oh
my god now he's defending dude this is
slicker is
glad you you told your chosen they can't
watch this okay we have to stop watching
[Laughter]
jokes aside Robert this is like the
advice we would give all our students
like you really have to forget the past
he's still beating himself up about
missing Queen takes e to and so it's
making him play more passive like he's
still totally winning but he's playing
worse and worse because he's he's pissed
about them what I can do is there's
something I can do okay he but he
brought the rook in whichever yeah
you're right that White's King is not
much safer than it was before and you're
down a queen for just one night and
slicker is noticing the time so you made
by too quickly someone yeah yeah oh
Ludwig loic's feeling the the life in
his position though I want to check me
him I mean you go from being just dead
loss to a better position like yeah you
okay he just gave us like the the
superhero my turn head crack like
someone comes at you Bam Bam Bam you go
my turn my turn oh wait don't let the
bad guys do that they might take all
your hits and like oh yeah I heard that
I was like wait yes oh really I needed
that oh are you trying to say this game
is pretty much
like going to chiropractor for you I
need to block yeah this is a so can you
adjust it after this one I threw out my
back an old chess injury back to my
shoulder at old pawn move an injury oh
man this game one that's it's still
going here and I think I I think Ludwig
is good over before before this could be
my name's move could be checkmate if I
move this here that's a check
[Laughter]
I've gotten check always check it might
be made I think I think mrs. chance
though before we'll have a good idea but
it's so fine its liquor gonna man dance
because he didn't realize that like what
all right now the Queen's under attack
but I don't think this liquors in
blenders gate but Ludwig's gonna have to
find King III if he goes King g5 he
loses the night I'm about to play here
and in the black Queen should go up to
g3 to get to safety then create some
attacks
okay Bria yeah no it's not over
I told you I think love was gonna win
this game somehow so I don't know
absolutely crazy he's not gonna win this
game
this guy's so boring I probably do it we
did this get so boring
that was liquor do you like Nike how
does he even speak
I'm yet I only speak English I don't
understand but yeah but sometimes I
don't know if he's speaking to you is
this
alright I'm gonna protect this and I'm
gonna try to bring another queen I'm
stuck I'm stuck I'm stuck him escape
found Queen g3 down your move dispersing
hair by the way Robert this is one of
those funny moments where the night is
like a perfect offender there's a very
good chance that slicker blunders his
queen on the next move I'm not kidding
he's not gonna one this Queen he's not
blending this clean I know you're
looking away you don't want to see it
happen
he's not gonna blunders we got a million
chats going here good if I move to say
he can't sis Chucky's Sheila tricksters
five seconds just meeting he's playing
for the clock it's a young girl at the
moment five seconds he's got it he's
doing this he's doing it now he's got
roaches chill circuits this is okay
slicker proved me wrong you're gonna win
right now I can't wait to talk to him
afterwards because I'm gonna be like hey
oh my god Annie over here said you
weren't gonna win this game and I had
his back yeah you did
[Laughter]
[Music]
every beginner or the new chess players
thoughts like thought yeah yeah let's
stay on me I don't know me oh I just
love going for the stalemate
you're what are you gonna do when they
come for you
bad boys bad boys yeah he's got made one
really actually fun to check me this
time no I said you ain't gonna win you
ain't gonna win boo boo boo boo boo boo
boo boo boo waste time this is what you
get for this mate I'm gonna waste time
two minutes I wish my time let me
blossom two pie
oh my gosh just take it like a man right
now just sitting there just try not to
get too upset I mean I feel upset
Chad it's alright let him have his W you
think I'm gonna play my actual opening
for 50 gifted subs look 50 gifted is
great but it doesn't double my sub count
I'm not GM's licker a consolation
bracket with 4k at the top I need to
focus on and I'm not dreaming about the
qaddafi acts like his openings are like
grand master level preparation it's an
exhibition boys in his openings are
grand master what was that on the
website was out on chest so much as like
did they hear that oh we heard it oh my
god they didn't hear that god I tried my
heart out
oh that's so frustrating unbelievable oh
my god Oh Danny you know I appreciate
they're very different styles of humor
like yeah slicker is non-stop he's very
fast-paced loving is a little more like
team and then just trying to get you
with those one-liners
yeah it just explodes when you don't
expect it oh my gosh this was absolutely
wild in the end it goes the way I guess
it should have if you're just tuning in
slicker missed the checkmate won all the
way back on move 18 and instead of
playing Queen take C to checkmate
he literally lets the game go on for a
very very long time it eventually does
way I have to give slicker shadow
because of course he's hilarious
but his chest was actually really good I
know he missed checkmates it was yeah
shoot him with himself but the way he
handled just the game from the very
start was quite impressive yep you think
it's safe to a slicker if his emotions
ever get the best of him is there any
question seat I'm slicker he would take
it where he wants it to go yeah we're
all victims to the conversation of
whoever slicker wants to go I um I don't
even know what else to say right now or
what we're supposed to do or whether
we'll ever be the same I mean the world
is changing before our very eyes where
Jen you say absolutely crazy okay I'm
told we're gonna take a very very quick
break
hey Cara Nakamura has been watching us
in the background while he plays blitz
so we'll let him have the floor for a
second as you and I prepare for some
interviews and then the final moments
here on today's pogchamp don't go
anywhere we'll be right back hey sticker
from GM BGM you know he went
I am I'm with Danny that's deer there's
this pink like that's pink like when you
speak I speak it's pretty lucky
let's go ahead I do a sincerely
apologize for my I'm not used to this
you know kindness from you but anyway
from GM the GM I like the bargaining
that you're doing you just just take his
money it's a it's a win-win for slicker
lose for love like no matter what lo big
respect a lot to put on the line what I
respect it I do see you as one of the
favorites in the consolation but firstly
I let me just say this okay yeah this is
gonna fit to do with the no twig
accuracy I was nine eighty nine percent
accuracy I think I might be the highest
of all
all right outside of outside of most
critical that's cuz he only had to play
six moves eighty nine percent and I lost
mine was higher than your slicker so as
I play an opening that's functional in
e4 alright I throw out the Berlin what's
a bill in okay this is super Mario
pixelated Andy you lost just lost and
you trying to use that as an excuse I
know what you trying to do but no you
couldn't come up with an excuse why
would you laugh are you an ear so just
jump oh no swing your life wait sorry I
do we do now recommend say swearing in
your life look uh what's the more than
we could he see I swear I swear Donna my
mom's life no I swear down
slicker do you struggle controlling your
emotions what do you mean by that I was
just asking watching the game you were a
little bit up and down when you miss
this checkmate in one I know it's just
too hard you know like I got blood
pumping in my veins and I feel like I'm
ready to win but I just don't think I
wish it not like believe this and I say
you know why did you do that
why I Russia I need to play patiently
you know patience is a virtue right so I
need to stop playing very patient and
he'd start ich you Layton each move I
see and he muted himself and he's going
on a long time
wait you muted yourself buddy I was
waiting for it silent solo big nose
finally your chance of speed hey by the
way your blindfold play is amazing yeah
yeah blindfold against him I didn't have
enough time though ten minutes is too
short I ever got better blindfolded cuz
I can't see the blunders but I saw your
game against box box that was so
impressive I was say like him I need to
play very smart and my patience my
patient right I brush all my plays and
like it's not smart I just see it and
then that's it you know like I think of
like oh I'm gonna win this now I need to
start playing very patient don't worry
this is just like a little good week was
a toy you know you just throw it it's
like a used toy like I said like a toy
story whether but you know like you just
use him you just throw him away you know
all hey that's a Yorkie from that's it
exactly yeah he's he's just useless he's
like a minion from League of Legends you
could say that right yeah like he's just
absolutely so your SID
[Laughter]
Oh
childish films he doesn't have that
remix Ludwig because I know you're
preparing hard we got to show you the
one moment in this game that could have
turned things around after you didn't
get mated
you fought all the way back and right
here we're gonna let you solve a puzzle
rush style white to play rook in the
game you played rook takes d6 what could
you and play here
Brooke before that's right rook before
pain I don't think he would have seen I
think it's e to check with with with his
rook and then and then he goes B to with
his rook and then I take Queen he takes
rook and I probably would've end up a
hole last Queen you know uh but didn't
see it and you know information for the
future
slicker you did play great and you stuck
with it you got the mate I mean I know
the chest isn't the most important thing
in some ways but it is yeah after like
four checkmates in MO I you know I'm
gonna say this early but you guys won't
believe it I knew it was like you know I
do like it for a show you know like
where people think like because I'm
obviously a highly intellectual you see
let me just be I'm gonna come across I
am an actor on Twitch I pursue in like
greatness features so like I
instigate like my behavior so people see
me as like oldies is doing this
fantastic no absolutely that's immature
and I'm it's very stupid of me you know
it's like what I do is like on purpose
so people can like you know spam like
log W so that's why I do those fake
place I news check me I notice took me
from the star but I just said you know
what I want to see Ludwick just lose
like in pain and agony that's why I
waited um BM do you 1 million five
minutes
I want minute 51 seconds okay I made you
wait because all that talk you have done
and that's what your mouth may bow down
cuz if we ever rematch please easy win
like xqc good week seriously
I'm doing this for the wedding I think
I'm good to win this I might if we
rematch right hundred gifted on the line
are you my name pain I'm paying listen
are you paying not a hundred gifted
if I beat you and we rematch I want to
tweet on your Twitter account oh and if
you beat me I'll let you tweet off mine
no it's no money it's free it's a tweet
you see it listen do I look you know
what you just saw ladies get fried okay
I'll do it's official just just open
your Twitter for me
and if I win I get your Twitter details
well that's going a bit too far honestly
it was just an easy game I just don't
understand nobody know what I want to
say this listen to this guys
Ludwick is not bad guy when I say this
all right everyone forsen I love him
excuse me I love him you rob I love him
look we go love him but you know he's
just like you're just gonna have to
shoot some shots on these guys cuz their
confidence is what pisses me off they
think they can win okay I lost a
foursome and who else but still they
think they can win well calm down mate
oh yeah 0:06 with GG don't ever
disrespect me I want to sorry at least
say sorry for that because you started a
okay well pologize we can all just hang
out sometime I'm being told that I don't
know I'm being told this has been
fantastic and probably we're moving
forward with the best of luck - good
luck wig in the next round and a
congrats on the gifted sub you guys
literally made the show today so thank
you for stepping up with an exhibition
match and maybe there's another one of
the few match is there another match
today
no you were the grand finale how is it
that we're the finale yeah we've seen
the best for last
god
Oh Oh little big just killed the show I
love that